le vaccin spoutnik vérifiable à 95% une
information fournie par le centre de
recherche gamaleya de mouches coup des
résultats préliminaires obtenus sur des
volontaires 42 jours après l'injection
de la première dose un taux de réussite
similaire à celui des laboratoires
occidentaux files heures band take et
modern art elles les autorités russes
ont d'ores et déjà annoncé que ce vaccin
il serait abordable et coûterait moins
de 10 dollars par ado on va en parler
justement avec notre correspondant à
moscou antoine claireaux fin enfin
bonjour quelles sont vos informations et
bien le patron russe le patron du fonds
russe d'investissements a fait savoir
qu'une dose de vaccin spoutnik vais vous
l'avez évoqué ne dépasserait pas les 10
dollars et sachant qu'il faut deux
injections pour une vaccination optimale
cela ne fera donc pas plus de 20 $ la
vaccination complète soit un peu moins
de 17 euros
d'après ce même responsable le spoutnik
versera 2 à 3 fois moins cher que ses
concurrents pour une efficacité
équivalente quelques spots iv mais que
le premier des vaccins russe d'autres
vont bientôt arriver sur le marché
écouter
comme vous le savez le premier vaccin
dans le monde contre le courant navires
us food me lever a été mis au point en
russie est déjà utilisé le deuxième
vaccin épi vague corona a déjà été
enregistré maintenant l'objectif clé est
de lancer leur production de masse ici
en russie est passé à une vaccination de
masse
notre troisième vaccin sera bientôt
disponible
nous sommes prêts à partager
l'expérience que nous avons accumulée
avec tous les états et structures
internationales intéressées avec nombre
de partenaires étrangers
nous examinons déjà la possibilité
d'organiser la production de ce vaccin
sur le terrain en s'appuyant sur la base
de production de nos partenaires
la coopération avec des laboratoires
partenaires est déjà bien avancé en inde
en corée du sud au brésil ou encore en
chine
suffisamment pour afficher l'objectif
des 1 milliard de doses de quoi vacciner
500 millions de personnes par an et ce
dès 2021
alors bien sûr on a assisté ces
dernières semaines à une véritable
surenchère concernant l'efficacité
supposée des différents vaccins contre
lacko vide actuellement en phase
d'essais cliniques mais quoi qu'il en
soit avec le spoutnik v la russie se
targue d'avoir en sa possession un
vaccin efficace et peu coûteux et une
certaine longueur d'avancé sur la
concurrence
merci beaucoup à vous antoine gayraud
pour toutes à ces précisions